monsieur la photographe il a fini par la
voix avait tant pis si la signature est
illisible c'est maman qui va être
contente
premier gros attroupement sur la très
sélecte plage de l'excelsior
on a même demandé aux carabiniers de
venir faire barrage par monsieur
mastroianni est là pour travailler une
journée à venise une seule pour le
service après vente comme il dit
40 interviews en 10 heures une journée
particulière j'ai bien parce que là
l'amitié avec un producteur
je suis dans la merde est jamais
j'ai tout dépensé life au match no pour
soutenir il faudrait que la mise et on
le mettait un terme et famille de m
annonce un bond à logements manquent
après voilà on fait tout pour ses
parents tous les responsabilités parce
qu'on est nous avait dit à la télévision
qu elle qui faisait beau c'est pas vrai
du tout 150 films l'acteur fétiche de
fellini a pris un malin plaisir à casser
son image de light in love her et il
continue dans un deux trois soleil
il est un père alcoolique pour un look
grimbert et dans le film argentin des
sonos et abla il joue un prince qui
épousent humaine
alors moi je vis pour rigoler moi je
vais te dire que moi je suis moi les
femmes le latino maire de mer de sète à
la boillat noyer je vais pas me faire ma
belle ou même des femmes
je les aime toutes c'est la comédie du
jour ouais alors fini en suivant la maco